Hallo, guten Tag, mein Name ist Görbes, ich bin als Assistenz, als Pentatee in der Notaufnahme und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Geschichte führen.
Ist das für Sie noch? Ja. Okay.
Okay.
Gut.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Georg Heidbreda.
Könnten Sie bitte vor und nach Namen buchen, tabieren?
Ja, Georg ist G-E-O-R-G.
Georg. Okay.
Und nach Namen?
Nachname ist Heidbreda, ist ein großes H, E-I-T-B-R-E-D-E-R.
Okay.
Heidbreda.
Herr Heidbreda, wie alt sind Sie?
67.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 21. Juli 1964.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,76 m und 84 kg.
84 kg.
Okay.
Heidbreda, was für welche Art haben Sie? Wie kann ich Ihnen heißen?
Ja, ich habe ganz starke Bauchschmerzen seit ungefähr 24 Stunden, seit einem Tag.
Ich habe starke Bauchschmerzen mehr so oben im Bauch.
Errechterseite oder linke Seite?
Na, in der Mitte und vielleicht ein bisschen mehr nach links, aber Mitte und links mehr.
Sind Sie schmerzlos aufgetreten oder langsam aufgetreten?
Sie sind langsam aufgetreten, aber sehr schnell stark.
Können Sie bitte die Schmerzen beschreiben, erdumpf oder druckend oder qualifizierend?
Ja, Sie sind mehr dumpf, so dumpf und rückend.
Manchmal kommen und gehen Sie so, aber Sie gehen nie weg.
Es ist manchmal so wie eine Welle, aber erdumpf.
Okay.
Ich verstehe.
Schmecken Sie die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Ja, so ein bisschen in den Rücken und auch teilweise in die linke Schulter habe ich den Eindruck.
Und wie schmecken Sie die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskalifon 1 bis 10?
Wobei 1, der leicht stark, der stark nicht schmeckt, wenn Sie bitte.
1 bis 10.
Na, 8.
Okay.
Haben Sie etwas bemerk, was Sie schmerzen, verschnehmert oder lingert oder auslöst?
Am besten ist, wenn ich mich hinlege, so ein bisschen, und die Knie etwas anziehe.
Ich habe dann probiert eine Wärmflasche, aber das war nicht so gut.
Okay.
Und ich fand das jetzt nicht positiv.
Ich verstehe.
Mit angesogenem Beinen, perbissen, sich schmerzen, steichen.
Wenn ich die Knie etwas anziehe, ist es etwas besser, aber nur etwas.
Okay, nicht.
Haben Sie dagegen eingenommen, Medikamente, ich meine?
Ja, ich habe Paracetamol genommen, zwei Tabletten, aber die haben nicht geholfen.
Ich verstehe.
Haben Sie eine zusammenhängende, siebischen Nahrungsaufnahme und Schmerzen bemerkt?
Hab ich nicht verstanden, können Sie nochmal sagen?
Nahrungsaufnahme.
Ja.
Und Schmerzen gibt es zusammenhängen?
Also ich habe, seit gestern, seit eben die Schmerzen gekommen sind, habe ich keinen Appetit, habe ich nichts gegessen.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Nur etwas getrunken.
Und hatten Sie ähnliche Beschwerden für die Änderung online?
Nein, habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Okay, und haben Sie Übelkeit, Arbrielschen?
Ja, Übel ist mir und ich habe auch zweimal erbrochen.
Wie sieht das Arbrielschen aus?
Ach, das war so schleimig, bisschen gelb-grün.
Haben Sie Durchfall oder Versturzung?
Nein.
Fühlen Sie sich fibrig?
Nein, aber ich fühle mich irgendwie, ja, ich bin jetzt ziemlich müde, weil ich heute Nacht nicht gut geschlafen habe wegen der Schmerzen.
Ich verstehe.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass ich Fieber habe.
Haben Sie nicht gemessen?
Nein.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen Kartschweißigkeit aufgefallen?
Heute Nacht habe ich etwas geschwitzt.
Das habe ich beim Nachtentgenerkt.
Das war ziemlich feucht, ziemlich nass.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Gewicht auf oder zugenommen?
Nein, das habe ich immer ein bisschen zu viel, sagt mein Arzt.
Ich wiege zu viel.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Erlassungs- oder Stuhlgang?
Nein, ich habe mal vor drei oder vier Jahren mal eine Darm-Spiegelung machen lassen, eine Vorsorge-Darm-Spiegelung.
Die war in Ordnung.
Okay.
Wasser lassen, ich muss einmal nachts auf Toilette, einmal Passellis.
Einmal nass.
Vor vier Jahren war ich in Ordnung, dass ich die Darm-Spiegelung durchschleffelte.
Können Sie mir hier heute?
Der Ton war irgendwie jetzt verzerrt.
Der war nicht in Ordnung.
Eine Minute.
Können Sie mich hören?
Ja.
Okay.
Hier die Darm-Spiegelung für vier Jahre.
Durchgefür.
Vor drei oder vier Jahren war eine Darm-Spiegelung.
Aber es war eine aus Vorsorge.
Ich hatte keine Beschwerden.
Das war in Ordnung.
Ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Bulut im Urin bemert?
Nein.
Okay.
Ja.
Ich habe einige Fragen vorerkrankt.
Haben Sie einen ersten Konjunkturerkrankt?
Ja, ich habe, muss Tabletten nehmen gegen den Zucker.
Ich habe meinen Arzt, ich habe Alterszucker.
Alterszucker.
Tabletten nehme ich so seit zehn Jahren.
Okay.
Und welche Tablette nehmen Sie ein?
Ich habe die Tabletten im Urin.
Okay.
Und welche Tablette nehmen Sie ein?
Ich habe hier das auf dem Zettel stehen.
Für den gegen den Zucker nehme ich Metformin.
Welche Dosis nehmen Sie?
Den 850.
Morgens eine halbe.
Und abends eine ganze.
Okay.
Und noch etwas Medikamente nehmen Sie ein?
Ja, dann nehme ich noch Alu-Porinol.
300.
Morgens eine halbe.
Ich hatte mal zweimal bisher einen Gichtanfall.
Ach so, ich weiß nicht.
Großgelenge, das war sehr scherzhaft.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie Gicht?
Oh, fünf Jahre vielleicht.
Ich weiß nicht genau, aber circa fünf Jahre.
Ja, ich weiß nicht genau, aber circa fünf Jahre.
Mein Blutdruck war etwas erhöht.
Das war schon länger her, ich schätze,
weil zwölf Jahre.
Dann nehme ich auch ein Medikament ein.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie ein?
Das heißt, der Name ist schwierig für mich.
Kan-de-Satan.
Okay, Kan-de-Satan.
Welche Dosis und wie oft nehmen Sie ein?
Ich habe 8 Milligramm Stärke.
Morgens eine Tablette und abends eine halbe.
Eine halbe, okay, ich verstehe.
Nehmen Sie gelegen sich oder bei Bedarf Medikament ein?
Nein.
Früßend sind jetzt die Schmerz-Tabletten gestern,
aber wir haben ja nicht verholfen.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Und wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Als Kind am Blinddamm.
Ja, aber wie alt ich da war, weiß ich nicht genau.
Als Kind habe ich auch eine Mandel-Operation.
Okay.
Beide Operationen waren,
die Komplikationen waren,
alles in Ordnung.
Okay.
Ich verstehe.
Herr Heilbratter, haben Sie Allergie und Unfallstärke
gefeiert und jede Nethwas?
Nein, ich habe keine Allergien.
Ich frage auch alles vom Essen.
Ich soll ja nicht alles essen wegen dem Zucker.
Aber ich frage auch.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Okay. Rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauch es schon ziemlich lange.
Seit wann?
Seit, ich bin jetzt 67, seit 45 Jahren.
Also, so waren es 20 Jahre und seit?
45 Jahre.
Und wie viel Zigaretten rauchen Sie?
Eine Schachtel, 20 Zigaretten am Tag.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, Bier.
Eine Flasche abends und manchmal einen Schnaps.
Aber manchmal.
Herr Heilbratter, nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Ich wohne mit meiner Frau zusammen.
Und wir haben drei Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Die älteste Tochter mit 33 hat Asthma
und hat eine Schildrösen-Unterfunktion.
Aber die anderen sind gesund
und sonst sind die gesund.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Sind Sie in Rezner, ich glaube?
Ich bin jetzt seit einem anderen Tag in Rente.
War vorher Elektriker.
Okay.
Sind Ihre Eltern in Leben noch, oder?
Mein Vater ist mit 80 Jahren gestorben.
Woran ist der Geschwister?
Ein Darmkrebs.
Und die Mutter, die ist jetzt 90 Jahre alt.
Die hat Alterszucker auch und hat Knochenschwund.
Also so brüchige Knochen.
Okay.
Was ist das Geschwister?
Ich habe einen Bruder.
Der Bruder hat eine Herzinfarkt gehabt vor zwei Jahren.
Er hat auch hohen Blutdruck und etwas Zucker.
Ich verstehe.
Und hat er nicht geimpft?
Ja, genau.
Ich habe auch diese Corona-Impfungen
in der Erleihung gekriegt.
Und heute, Britta, haben Sie Atemnot?
Nein, Atemnot habe ich nicht.
Herzstortern, Herzklopfen.
Ich habe noch nie festgestellt.
Diese Kontrollen beim Hausarzt, der hat mal EKG geschrieben.
Das war in Ordnung.
Und Ihre Blutzucker und Blutdruck gut angestellt?
Ja, ich war das letzte Mal da vor acht Wochen.
Dann nimmt der Doktor immer so einen, sagt er Langzeitwert.
Und damit war er ganz zufrieden.
Er sagt nur, ich soll mein Gewicht.
Ich soll Gewicht abnehmen.
Okay, ich farsche.
Das ist schwer.
Ja, okay.
Herr Heilbrat, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Müssen Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Was habe ich?
Was habe ich noch nie gehabt, Schmerzen?
Was kann das sein?
Ja, ich verstehe Sie.
Zuerst werde ich körperliche Untersuchungen.
Danach werde ich Blut abnehmen
und das Haus durchführen.
Und je nachdem, wie es kommt, können wir wieder schießen.
Okay?
Okay.
5 Minuten für Sie.
Ja, es ist für mich.
Hat jemand Frage oder?
Keine.
Eine Frage?
Ich höre nichts.
Ich habe eine Frage, nur eine differenzielle Diagnose.
Hatten Sie seit Beginn, ich sehr beschmerzen,
einmal Stuhlgang oder gehen wir ab?
Also, seit gestern habe ich jetzt keinen Stuhlgang gehabt.
Ich habe sonst immer so einmal am Tag alle 1,5 Tage Stuhlgang.
Aber ich habe ja auch nichts gegessen seit gestern, alles so wehtat.
Okay, danke schön.
Gut, sagen wir 5 Minuten.
Okay, keine.
Okay.
Hallo, guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Ich bin als Assistenz, Synthetik in der Not-Ausnahme.
Ich würde gerne einen neuen Potienten vorstellen.
Ich habe es dir gesagt.
Okay.
Ich habe alle 5 Minuten gemacht.
Ich habe die 1,5 m2, 1,5 kg,
Die Menschen sind auf der Strecke und auf der Schutze.
Und die Menschen, die die Menschen, die die Parastrophen
haben, haben sie nicht gewonnen.
Und mit Angesorgung beinahe und Wärmelfrasche,
verbesserst sich ein bisschen.
Auch mit der Wärmflasche?
Nein.
Wärmflasche hat der Patient gesagt, war nicht so gut.
Ach so, okay.
Bei Wärm, ferschlimmer, verstichlich,
schmerz.
Ja.
Okay.
Und, ähm,
Auslöden, Klarktö, Darfurthien,
Übva, Ila-Petens,
Nozjans, Zwei-Mallegge,
Schidami-Gong,
Georgina, Emelis.
Ja.
Und, äh,
Fragana, äh,
Mition, Defekation,
Schütterung,
äh, Gebitferendrung,
Fibam,
Disney,
Tashikardi,
äh,
Und, äh,
Vorher ein Hebischwerden,
wurde verneint.
Okay.
Und, äh,
Hat der Patient Risikofaktoren?
Äh, wofür?
Ja, allgemein Risikofaktoren.
Ja, der Patient ist übergewicht.
Und, äh,
Errautlofin und Ertlinge-Alkohol.
Also, er hat ein Nikotin-Hapusus.
Genau.
Und, äh,
Übergewichtig, gibt es sonst Grunderkrankungen?
Äh, ja, gibt es Grunderkrankungen.
Er leidet seit 12 Jahren Artilienekipartoni.
Und, äh, seit 10 Jahren Diabetes-Meleutistipsiwein.
Und seit 5 Jahren, äh,
Ürünthgicht, äh, ja.
Hyper-Uri-Chemie?
Ja, Hyper-Uri-Chemie.
Hyper-Uri-Chemie, ja.
Und, äh,
Der Patient nimmt Besitz-Dischmedikamente, äh,
Eine andere.
Kandisarter, 8 Milligramm,
I'm My Morgans und eine halbe Abund.
Okay.
Metformin, 80 Milligramm,
eine halbe Tablette, Morgans und
I'm My Abund.
Und Allöpferne, äh,
3,4 Milligramm,
eine halbe Tablette, Morgans, ein.
Und, äh,
Der Patient,
Burada als Kind, Appendectomiert und
Transillektomiert,
Debyte Operationen waren, äh,
Koopifikationslos, äh,
Perlafen.
Okay.
Äh, beiden Patienten, äh,
Ist keine Allergie und verträglich,
sind keine Allergen und verträglich
Kalten betan.
Ja.
Er ist la,
für 4, 4, 4,
äh,
Einfach, einfach, äh,
Teknis,
Zigarette, äh,
und das Entschiebrit,
für 4, 4,
Packiers.
Mhm.
Er trinkt, äh,
einflasche,
abends und geregentisch,
Schnapp,
für ein,
paar
Ek Bangkok,
Malgenkarsinon, vielleicht.
Und ja, Ulcus ventricioli.
Kann sein.
Und ja, noch andere.
Acute colitisitis, vielleicht.
Denken Sie an das Organ, was retroperitoneal liegt.
Und wenn es.
Würde ich zumindest dran denken.
Ausstrahlen in den Rücken, in die linke Schulter.
Und dieser dumpfe Schmerz.
Hat vorher keine Gewichtsabnahme.
Das Malgenkarsinon würde ich sagen, macht wahrscheinlich doch
eine Gewichtsabnahme.
Die Zeit.
Meine Arbeitshypothese wäre akute Pankreatitis.
Differenzial diagnostisch.
Vielleicht Ulcus duodini.
In der Richtung.
Oder auch einer Cholizistitis.
Aber dagegen spricht er wohl kein Fieber.
Hat er Fieber?
Ich merke, dass die schütteren in linke Seite.
Also bei der Schulizistitis oder Galen
würden wir vielleicht eher die rechte Schulter.
Vermuten.
Also ich würde sagen, nach der Schilderung wäre meine
Verdachtstiagnose Pankreas.
gute Pankreatitis.
Wahrscheinlich keine chronische Pankreatitis.
Er hat ja verneint, er hat solche Schmerzen so noch nie gehabt.
Ja, aber er hat Risikofaktoren.
Alkohol.
Also ich glaube, Richtung akute Pankreatitis
auf alle Fälle diagnostizieren.
Ist der Patient exikiert?
Nein.
Da sollten Sie daran denken.
Und dann ist es nicht so,
dass man sich nicht mehr auf die Schmerzen
und dann muss man sich daran denken.
Vielleicht, wenn der Patient fragt, was habe ich,
sagen körperliche Untersuchungen.
Das haben Sie sehr gut gesagt.
Und ich werde Blut abnehmen.
Bei der Gelegenheit werde ich Ihnen einen Zugang legen,
wo Sie eine Info...
Ich habe eine Info...